[Music]
in dirty fetish news in japan japan
submitted but Rihanna's forehead why you
just pin the record right now DJing is
part so yeah woman who's made at $65,000
from selling her period pads and toenail
clippings is urging others do you think
it's sexual I guess cuz yeah this comes
every month yeah it's a never-ending
supply who wants to buy period pads by
the way Japanese a lot of men that's
like there's more of a fetish
understanding there then there are
toenail clipping yeah there's a there's
a Japanese fetish where they want to
tuck the toke rust the toe jam they want
to smell the cheese they want to smell
in between the nail and the [ __ ] thumb
you know yeah [ __ ] I didn't start
selling random [ __ ] I not address all
this and like maybe you should know what
oh my all my swimsuits and bikinis from
go-go dancing I think me good money off
of it you still have a it's like they
want to jack off to the sweat of you
Timmy puts him on with over jogs what
make you funky
well apparently this girl she's such a
pro that she already has like a sort of
solution that will mimic her wearing
these underwear for so many days what is
it like Cetaphil face wash it she just
goes to the gym I have no idea [ __ ]
on a day that she has a period should
you run a marathon that's amazing i can
actually like she she made like a
solution i don't know what it is though
i think what she should do is not wipe
her ass after she takes a [ __ ] put that
dog on and go run
and you can like go to your friends for
their toenail clippings watch like I go
to Bart and send ones there like this
big oh no all right so this girl her
name is Jasmine obviously that's not her
name or Yasmine I need to see what she
looks like
there's no photo she's anonymous or
trying to remain anonymous she's still
ashamed huh she says that only her close
friends and family members I know what
she does for a living but she doesn't
publicly go out their house and also she
says that she's gotten requests for her
underwear socks bras I have almost used
past I have all those things I can do
the hot hair I have a plenty of that one
day you gonna do with your drink foot
shavings I don't want them to have my
dinner because they're gonna they're
gonna use it at a murder to hide their
trail see nobody man you have you have a
chill a paper trail that says no I sold
it to this person oh yeah well fYI my
toenails are all over the world so she's
saying that by her doing this she's made
over sixty five thousand dollars and
she's also gotten furniture paid for her
groceries her bills designer clothing
even luxury holidays with her boyfriend
all paid for by these guys because she
also found someone that she calls a pay
Pig Oh a fin dong yeah so there's guys
who get off on women telling them I give
me your [ __ ] money all of it
everything you're making your paycheck
you give it to me and then they get off
on that so they just get a [ __ ] in the
money they like we women dominate their
wallets I saw this porno and it's called
it's it's it's called fandom right and
then girls are just like in normal
clothes or business suits and the guys
like naked and then they're like making
fun of his dick and talking [ __ ] to um
and I'm all like this this is not making
me horny this is kind of hurting my
feelings like I feel bad for this guy
look at your little reader and then they
start touching him and I'm like ah
that's why he goes through with it you
know yeah girl she actually provided
screenshots of her and her pay pigs
conversation so is what it looks like so
we really knit together morning hashtag
candy cane how may I serve you today you
can start by paying for my grocery
shopping followed by homework items I
have added to my wish list please miss
hashtag candy cane let me buy these
items you desire and in return could I
please have a pair of your pink laced
worn panties you know they're my
favorite but favorite spelled wrong
[Laughter]
favor right he checks again good evening
hashtag candy cane is there anything
else you require for me before I retire
for the night I shall be dreaming of you
dreams cost payment Pig please candy
how much is worthy of your dreams she's
like excuse me please forgive me candy
kid how much is worthy of her dreams if
he only called her candy her name is
candy cane because when she says five
hundred should should do the deed you
will send it immediately your payment
has been sent sent as requested I love
it when you dream me goodnight Wow until
sunrise oh my god I don't understand
this world man I might be way too
[ __ ] cheap to be a part I'm cheap too
because I might be opposite like I can't
understand how that is cuz if I picture
myself in this guy's shoes I will start
getting angry at the girl well you
you're not you're you're dumb you're on
a submissive you guys are all sub that
felt amazing Oh
how the [ __ ] does that feel good
blackmail - I've seen where like women
are like you will send me a thousand
dollars and I will tell your wife what
kind of dirty [ __ ] you are and you
think no please no and then that's what
they get off on I have a couple friends
I do you know I think it's because
please my bank account because if they
had a different situation with let's say
the girl was like how about this I'll
pay you and I'll [ __ ] you and then
they're like oh this is better
well not looks like that's like saying
if you're into anal sex and girls like
you know what maybe you'll like it
better let me put it in your butt that
doesn't work that way I don't think he's
tried it yet I don't think he's tried it
yet I will [ __ ] suck the [ __ ] out of
your dick you piece of [ __ ] he still
gets to talk to like that but he gets
money now you know
oh my you take this [ __ ] money and
I'll suck you off like there's the cure
to cancer in that [ __ ] what does it mean
yeah what does it make me if if a girl
comes to me fail single she says very
nice things to me
she gives me money buys me whatever I
want [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of me what does
that make me that's the opposite of
these guys right that's your your your
left there's a term for I'm sorry you're
a what is it a kept boy I'm a toy but
I'm a boy toy that's a title mm-hmm so
I'm the pool boy how do you know this
stuff I have very interesting friends I
can't trust me I do you could be a
billionaire right now do you see how
much opportunity she keeps oddly no what
is wrong with you you could be so damn
rich right now we're fans I messaged me
like I want to be your slave
like whatever ball ball but I can't like
I'm like okay how about I'll message
them you know I'll do it yeah
that's right you punk-ass [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah I'll talk [ __ ] to him
all day that's right you [ __ ] we dick
little [ __ ] they want to be your slave
they'll like polish your shoes
I just picture this guide a top hat and
I like a white towel he's like dear
mistress like what can I do to be your
white Butler and like wait like
specifically what like you were buying
me groceries baby like versus like he
was a white Butler he's like I don't
know if Asian women like it but I am a
white man I want to be your Butler I'm
like okay that's they don't want to meet
me they just want to have me spend their
money no I can't do it like there's
there's actually websites fetlife it's a
website for fetishes and they're
specific categories like this is the
category that you want to be in whatever
I can't post my picture on there because
someone's gonna be like hey you know
what's up but let me enjoy a music [ __ ]
exactly but that's a you little [ __ ]
freak with the [ __ ] you still driving in
that Lambo outside with your best friend
David next to you I can't help it I
can't [ __ ] myself their money that's
not boring that's ever for me like yeah
you poor cuz I'm gonna do it I'm gonna
make you into it I'm telling you man
people want to see this [ __ ] you you
they want to see you on top you're not a
partner because I wanna cut it if you
guys see me on that life it's a three
man [ __ ] business meet if David I
kind of feel you Gina because I recently
realized that I'm not that money hungry
anymore
because I am
world's no that's not true it's not
money hungry that money hungry means no
morals but like I was jogging the other
day I saw a dollar on the floor and I
did not pick it up I just kept running
that was a full dollar like this on the
[ __ ] floor and I was like don't need
it don't need it took a lot for me to
resist because I told myself
someone needs that money for crack and
it's not money for crack and then I
imagined a two tooth crackhead that was
like down-on-his-luck and then he's like
and he went out there got a square a
crack and he was able to smoke that only
$1 nah
hey guys would you think of that video I
know you loved it so make sure to hit
that like button to watch more videos
check it out up here
[Music]